we are getting ready to film the very
first Jakob project in a long time you
stop making skits in 2014 we are trying
to find places to shoot today so
location scouting is a process you do
where you go to the actual location that
you can shoot at alright what's up
everybody today I have a production
meeting with all these fine people hello
everybody
these fine people are the key positions
they're gonna be the shot callers on set
over here we got Antoine will be
assistant director who is be my
right-hand man we're gonna keep him be
keeping us on schedule yeah our drying
soon you're gonna be the bad guy on set
I will rock a govt that Manabe in a Kyle
who was our sound guy on jkp yeah he
said his favorite kind of Av are the
ones who don't do that who kind of made
you please go to caucus it at bad cop
right you know not always being the one
who's like yelling on people's throats
like you know like being understanding
but then be persistent some balance
that's very hard to do but I think you
have the right attributes though cuz you
are you're always very positive every
time you're around us and you bring a
really cool energy of Jacob party for
one I'm also very blunt yeah you're very
blunt exactly you have two random ones
and you're also really organized we're
trying to pray on scripts so everyone
can read and be caught up how do you
feel about the mockumentary style that
we're filming the DP I think well as a
DP it's less amounts of things that I
need to control which is good but also
it's like it's not as dramatic as the
thing
that's true true but I think Casey can
agree no for sure like that you probably
want to set up I'm probably way more
complicated than we need to be we need
to like keep our mind I'm like this has
got to like fit that office slash like
nine one one slice cops kind of look we
have to make it like ghetto enough that
it's believable yep but we still need to
get all the information on the faces all
of the performances and stuff and do it
in a way that's funny too so you're sure
that a lot of it will be really funny to
shoot like I am super excited for a lot
of these prime zooms because I am like a
Jim Halpert like like yeah it's cool to
see like big growth in like well I mean
how many table reason we had how many
like different ideas have there been but
we're actually find the shooting one so
it's like it's pretty cool to see like
it actually come to be true true and and
then Brandon you would be our producer
along with Julia yeah pretty much
me and Juliana have to make sure all the
pieces are here true said every this
thing fails it's on your shoulder right
my shoulders not Nadine your shoulders
now Ryan shoulders and then Anton
shoulders but your shoulders Brandon is
no yours sleep over yesterday it's two
closest friends we just dropped them off
you also got a haircut yesterday oh so
did I - yeah we have to clean out the
living room now cuz look this is the
mess up they left behind Jeff one on
your hair slumber party yeah well a
sleepover sorry now summer party yeah I
know
is it I just said I know could I don't
want to sound stupid
I'm not afraid can you point the camera
to the mirror book this one yeah oh yeah
oh yeah is that what you want me to do I
was just trying to make it more
cinematic and now I feel stupid
I actually was laying here when the boys
were down here and I was just like oh my
phone is up spending time with them but
this is how many pillows I need to put
because this couch is so slippery
that all the pillows slide right off so
in order for me to be comfy I'm gonna
have a million pillows Oh true I can't
wait to get new couches for a house I
want to get rid of these these are nice
couches but okay wait why is this pillow
case you guys keep the moving pillow
case they had a doula foot fight last
night how was your summer party man let
me sleep over so much Heidi just loved
it how is it you like it awesome that's
awesome
yeah we played hide and seek in the dark
oh yeah oh that was EDA cute
yeah it's funny cuz I was I've been so
addicted to this Chromebook like on the
Chromebook this was a cool cooking cream
I've been so addicted to cookie crisps
that I was just like I'm sorry guys I
can't join you and playing in the dark
so I was the one playing on the
Chromebook everyone was trying to to
hide and then every time someone would
come cat come I past me did you put
stickers on the Xbox yeah oh I just
noticed that that's funny that's cute
okay anyway so it was pretty awesome cuz
I felt like the game master because then
sometimes like people will bring out
their the light like the flash
like to to search for people and I'd be
like no like so like you know how in in
Incredibles Edna mode it's like no capes
I was like no like it sounds like the
gamemaster
that's so true yeah we played in the
dark last night you played in the dark
we had those the the flashlights on
their heads yeah remember whenever I was
hiding behind the coat rack oh yeah and
you guys couldn't find me for a long
time and then you were the one that
found me so he came down here I'm like
oh something's wrong with the color
hanger like oh he's staying there I'm
like okay let's see how long you think
of find him because it was so obvious
that you're right there and they're like
alright good see you once you knew right
so and then I told them I'll go upstairs
and you'll look for something like no
I'm not gonna go without you you're like
just I I'll be up there and then they
left or like and then you was right
there okay I thought it was so obvious
why do you need confirmation yeah last
night's me of hide-and-go-seek was super
epic I was epic for me because I was
hiding for like a good maybe 30 minutes
and they're gonna find me my back was
hurting so the first one was behind this
coat rack and I put covers on top of me
to look like I was more coats and more
fabric next to the coat racks which
which then you'd be like oh yeah a coat
rack he's hanging stuff off the thing
there's some sort of mass of stuff so
like you just you kind of overlook it
right so that was my first hiding spot
the second time I was hiding next to
TIFF so she was just playing games on
the the bed and I figured I'll just hide
in plain sight this time but I'll get
really close to TIFF to make it look
like I'm part of Tiff's body or
something and it's like part of the the
coverage or whatever I don't know how
did you how did you find me I went on
the bed with one that's Chango before
that before you came out to the bed yeah
they were asking Google home they're
like hey Google where's Casey and then I
guess she said what was it BC and then
you guys were like behind clothes
clothes closet and then they found you
cousin Isaac notice that the bed a
little lumpy and then I was like yeah BC
behind Kony hat which is a Spanish word
for blanket when I was hiding behind the
coat rack they gave up right next to me
they were staying literally right in
front of me because they were like this
is crazy
one of the kids were like this is crazy
we're three kids that we can't find a
big man yeah so they're like literally
right beside me so that I may give up
and that's when I reached my hand out
yeah super epic game of hide-and-go-seek
last night no and then it was pretty
cool cuz we finally got to use this
thing that I bought on Amazon so
remember when we went camping and we had
a little spiky thing in the tent and I
was just like never again this is the
last time I go camping without something
on like some memory foam padding on the
bottom of the tent so then I bought this
thing but then I realized was this huge
so I'm like man I hope we actually go
camping again we had a big we gotta buy
new cars at least I forgot to use it
last night with his friends here true
true it's being used for something but
then I'm thinking like man in the new
house we don't have a lot of storage
space we really are losing space
compared to what we have here so I'm
like dang where is this thing gonna live
and you have
but then I spent all morning working at
Pinterest and pinning things for our
house and I'm so excited because on
Tuesday we're going to Design Center and
we're going to pick up flooring and
cabinets and window treatments and
countertops
by not a little bit yeah
you guys are doing a fantastic job by
the way okay speaking of the house I
wanted to answer some questions are you
guys head of our home uh-huh so I don't
know if I answered say it again but the
house is projected to be finished by
late December Oh cat hey so come here
yeah give him a ride keep it steady
Embry cat that's how Emperor's travel in
Kings are you okay yep what a luxury cat
you are so yeah house will be completed
so originally they said February and
then they raised it up to like mid
January and then now they're saying late
December so hopefully we'll be spending
Christmas in our new house but I highly
doubt it though let's just say in
January yeah and that's one another one
people were pointing out how close we
are to neighbors and that is definitely
a downside to this house because
obviously we would want like our land
like I'm a big property but the
developer we bought the house from
they're developing an entire community
and so it's really rare to have a
single-family brand-new home in Los
Angeles County it's like so rare so when
we found this we're like
we gotta hop on it it's pretty good but
yeah we do miss out on private space
like from our neighbors it is pretty
close but at least we get to own our own
four walls we don't share any walls so
that's the upside it is a two-story home
because then in like my Instagram people
are like whoa you're else looks really
small I'm like it's two stories so like
we get that um what other things that I
see about the house oh I saw something
oh why do you guys are really concerned
for us about the HOA you guys are like
don't do an HOA through the worst bla
bla bla bla bla
you guys aren't complaining I get you
like HOA can be a pain in the butt
that's hurt but what you don't know is
that I like the HOA I'm really quiet
resident I don't we don't throw parties
they don't do anything out of the norm
the reason why we might want to move out
of this place is because we're becoming
these old or the geezers like don't make
noise near me kind of people and that's
what we want to move away hopefully we
get to have some really cool decent
neighbors we have met one of our
next-door neighbors and they seem like a
really sweet family so and on the other
side of us I think there was a doctor
but I don't know yet fingers crossed
hopefully the HOA is gonna be a good
situation for us I have heard a lot of
nightmares it's a very good ring yes but
if the community gets really good the
right does know what for HOA but so now
hope I'm not looking for the neck it's
pretty good yeah starting is good yeah
or HOA fees it's a pretty cheap ho8
so nothing's gonna be perfect you know I
think ideally it's just brand new house
and then this is really our starter home
anyway so this is the home that we will
begin our home buying journey in like
the next few years I don't know we
project maybe like living there for
about like 7 years 7 to 10 years and
then we'll figure out another
situation who knows oh and I just
remembered another one - people are
saying would you get to design your
house like from the ground up think you
guys are building it yourselves
and then I was like I wish I wish we
could like move walls and like do
certain things but we can't we can't
alter the the floor of the game yeah the
game plan the floor plan yeah the floor
plan is it's there we just get to mess
with the aesthetics of it so like
countertops cabinets all that stuff
that's what we get to pick but the floor
plan itself we can't modify truly yeah
by the house and we do it ourselves yeah
yeah we do
it's the only sucky part the only thing
I'm really not looking forward to is the
fact that we can't change the way our
house looks on the outside yeah that's a
bummer that one cuz they have like
regulations the HOA it's okay it's not
that ugly but we would have preferred a
different look yeah okay
but in the words of my dad my ever wise
Papa Chan how often do you stand outside
and look stare your house yeah outside
you know it's like you're just gonna
spend most your time on the inside and
even when you're on the outside no one's
going look at my house look at the color
it is you know no one does that you you
spend most your time inside in the AC
and watching TV you know so as long as
it's quiet which is all I really want
quietness and peacefulness and family
time
[Music]
[Music]